Donald Trump has tried to craft a
narrative sort of a feeling that this
entire Russia meddling hacking collusion
Putin thing is just foreign to him right
he's going along being president and the
fake news media keeps talking about this
Russia thing but it's just not even
something that Trump is really aware of
and yeah the consensus among our
intelligence agencies is that it
happened it's just not really on Trump's
radar though it's a distraction that is
very very tangential to what Donald
Trump's awareness includes about
geopolitics and okay fine there have
been 32 indictments at this point but
it's a witch-hunt and it's a distraction
and it's just so confusing to Trump
because it doesn't jive with anything
else that he knows about well that
narrative that Trump just doesn't really
get why people are talking about this if
anybody still believed it has absolutely
and totally imploded because the New
York Times has now published a stunning
blockbuster report which reveals that
two weeks before Donald Trump's
inauguration not two weeks before the
recent Helsinki summit not two weeks
before the first indictments in the
Trump Russia scandal two weeks before
Trump became President of the United
States he was shown highly classified
information which indicated that Putin
personally ordered the cyber attacks
that were meant to influence the 2016
election as the report in The New York
Times says Trump resisted acknowledging
it but at the time he did seem convinced
of this reality and I want to remind you
again because this is just so key weeks
before the inauguration this confirms
that either Donald Trump has a really
acute memory problem so bad that really
he shouldn't be President of the United
States or it confirms that Trump's
entire attitude over the last year and a
half two years of I don't know what
they're talking about I don't really
believe it it is as we predicted a
complete and total farce and in fact
this New York Times article which we're
going to link to and I encourage you to
read it's extraordinarily well-written
and well
research it points out that there are
actually numerous instances when Donald
Trump was briefed on Russia and briefed
on Russia related intelligence and at
least privately the indication is that
he accepted it he didn't happily accept
it heed the word I believe that the New
York Times article uses as he grudgingly
accepted it but he did accept it so this
public thing of it could have been
anyone
why would Russia do it it's not ignorant
it's not poor memory by every indication
it's actually a proactive disinformation
campaign and when you look at how Trump
publicly sort of cast doubt around the
accusations this actually makes a lot
more sense because Trump has tried to
create meta-narratives rather than
denying the specific intelligence and
the methods and the sources that we know
that Russia has used in the past and
uses today Trump comes up with
meta-narratives to try to discredit the
entire thing like for example Democrats
are leading a witch-hunt it's not an
attack on the underlying information
it's just writing it off as politics
another example that in July of last
year Donald Trump tried to go with was
that Putin's the Russians Putin and the
Russians cyber hacking skills are so
good that if Russia really did do it
there wouldn't be any fingerprints on it
because Russia is so good at covering
their tracks or for example another
meta-narrative that Donald Trump has
used is that the intelligence community
just can't be trusted it's not reliable
or it's been politically subjugated and
still it's hard to get consensus about
the crisis that this represents and one
of the fundamental tenets of the type of
government that we have like if you
believe in representative democracy to
the extent that we have it in the United
States and of course the extent to which
we have it is increasingly is sort of
questionable you have to have elected
officials that have been elected by the
people their governing right and if
Russia influenced the election we
violated that basic principle and when
you have a president who not only has
had the knowledge of this for years but
continues to publicly deny it those
denials become increasingly concerning
and if Donald Trump truly believed that
the story wasn't real that it either
wasn't Russia or that it didn't happen
at all okay the guy's a [ __ ] and that's
one type of problem that we would have
to deal with but what's become
stunningly clear in the last couple of
weeks but especially with this new New
York Times report is that Trump does
know what's going on and he's known
about what was going on since two weeks
before the inauguration and the denials
and the misdirection and the counter
narratives are a proactive
disinformation campaign and I believe
that that makes them worse and the
effort started very quickly because
let's go back to a tweet from five days
after Donald Trump was briefed back in
January of 2017 about the Russian
meddling and he again grudgingly
accepted it intelligence agencies should
never have allowed this fake news to
leak into the public said Trump one last
shot at me are we living in Nazi Germany
that's January of 2017 Trump already
knew that he was telling untruths and
then just five weeks after the briefing
also back in 2017 Donald Trump tweeting
this Russian connection nonsense is
merely an attempt to cover up the many
mistakes made in Hillary Clinton's
losing campaign we now know because of
the reporting of the New York Times that
Trump knew what he was saying wasn't
true
back when he said it in 2017 it wasn't
ignorant it was dishonesty and then of
course he fired James Comey and he did
everything else that we know that he did
and the context within which we
understand that has been radically
altered by knowing that Trump weeks
before the inauguration accepted the
realities of the intelligence community
reporting on this but as usual what do
we come to what do we come to every time
we uncover another layer of the
atrocities that were committed we come
to what do we do Republican Party's not
going to hold them accountable it's not
clear to me that voters are going to
hold Trump and Republicans accountable
in November so what happens next I don't
have the answer I wish I had the answer
if
doesn't end the presidency not by itself
but as the culmination of this building
story that we've now had four weeks four
years rather I don't know that anything
will and that's probably the most
depressing reality that we've got to
come to terms with send me your thoughts
about this report and whether there will
ever be repercussions and consequences
for what we now know took place I'm on
Twitter at D Pakman and the show is on
twitter at david pakman show today's
program was made possible in part by
Blink accom slash Pakman i love bling
cast it's the really perfect app for
anybody who likes politics and learning
and if you're watching or listening to
the david pakman show I'm sure you'll
love politics and learning and what
blinka studs is take the best and most
popular non-fiction books they condense
them into 15-minute audiobooks that you
can listen to in one sitting and you can
learn about politics philosophy
psychology economics often we don't have
the time to actually read as many books
as we would like I know that I'm at my
limit for how much I can read and this
way you can absorb the most important
valuable information from books in just
15 minutes maybe on your way to work
maybe on your way to the gym maybe
cooking vegan recipes at home whatever
is your thing and our audience can get a
seven day free trial by going to blinka
scon slash Pakman if you're watching on
YouTube I've put a link in the video
description and after the free trial if
you like it and I think you will
you can continue enjoying thousands of
condensed audiobooks for just about five
bucks a month you can go to be li NK is
t.com slash PA k ma n to sign up